a lot of people are worried about how to
Stave off imminent catastrophic man-made
climate change well
Spanish climate Minister Teresa Ribera
has just showed the whole world how
Minister ministress Ribera recently
attended a climate change Summit hosted
by the European Union and she showed up
to the summit riding a bicycle and she
rode that bicycle for approximately 100
yards surrounded by emitting security
vehicles after she got out of a
limousine which she had entered after
stepping off a private jet
our own transportations are Pete bootage
pulled a similar stunt a couple years
ago sometime when he was not taking
maternity leave mayor Pete pulled up to
a cabinet meeting riding a bicycle
which a hidden camera caught him
unloading from the back of an armored
SUV just a few blocks off his
destination my favorite part of these
performances is that they actually
marginally increase pollution into the
air because the vehicles need to idle
while mayor Pete and the Spanish lady
prepare their bicycle rides but they are
worthwhile demonstrations nonetheless
because they show us a great example of
what we should sacrifice to the nature
gods
and it's precisely what they are
sacrificing to the nature gods and that
is precisely nothing right now text
Knowles to 98 98 98 as central banks in
countries such as China India and
Australia begin looking to transition to
a digital currency the Federal Reserve
has been contemplating the same for the
U.S with a digital currency the
government could track every single
purchase you make officials could even
prohibit you from purchasing certain
products or easily freeze or seize part
or all of your money Times Like These
are a great reminder to diversify a
portion of your savings into gold and
you can do that with the help of Birch
gold Birch gold is where I get my gold
so do thousands of other concerned
Savers Birch gold will help you convert
an existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in
Gold you don't pay a penny out of pocket
when currencies fail gold is a safe
haven how much more time does the Dollar
have protect your savings with gold
Birch gold has an eight plus rating with
the Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers text Knowles Canada wlas
to 98 98 98 get your free info kit on
gold if a central bank digital currency
becomes a reality it will be nice to
have a little bit of gold to depend on
text Knowles Canada wlas to 98 98 98
right now head on over to
goodranchors.com use promo code Knowles
if you have not heard yet the FDA
approved lab-grown chicken for sale yes
meat formed in a lab will soon be coming
to a store near you yuck if you prefer
meat grown in a pasture instead of a
petri dish then you need good ranchers
not only do they sell real meat from
real animals but they sell the best meat
this country has to offer from
Steakhouse quality cuts of beef to
better than organic chicken everything
good Rancher sources is from local farms
in America plus right now you will get
30 bucks off with my code Knowles at
goodranchers.com they've got terrific
products absolutely top tier stuff I had
their burgers the other night I almost
died they're so freaking good also you
can't call the scientists and lab to ask
about their fake meat but good ranchers
has a team of people available for you
to call and answer all your questions
real meat real service what are you
waiting for enjoy real meat real service
today with good ranchers good
ranchers.com use code Knolls for 30
bucks off any box promo code Knowles at
goodranchors.com goodranchors.com
American Meat delivered Mr zielinski
over there in Ukraine is furious that
NATO led by the United States is not
going to immediately enter into World
War III zielinski
is angry because while Joe Biden and the
West broadly has said that Ukraine can
eventually join NATO
Biden has said that Ukraine cannot join
NATO right now because if Ukraine joined
NATO right now well it's still engaged
in a war with Russia that would
instantly trigger Article 5 that would
instantly trigger a world war with a
nuclear former superpower something that
the U.S managed to avoid for the
entirety of the Cold War but this punk
in Ukraine wants to start it up right
now what is uh Mr zielinski say he says
it's unprecedented and absurd when time
frame is not set neither for the
invitation nor for Ukraine's membership
it seems there is no Readiness or
neither to invite Ukraine to Nato nor to
make it member of the alliance this
means that a window of opportunities
being left to bargain Ukraine's
membership in nato in negotiations with
Russia and for Russia this means
motivation to continue its Terror
uncertainty is weakness and I will
openly discuss this at The Summit
it's my best it's not quite my fouchy
impression but it's the best I can do
for zielinski and
in a way look I don't particularly care
Vera zielinski I don't care for U.S
foreign policy which has dragged this
war on needlessly I don't care for the
protestations of the liberal
establishment which for decades now has
been provoking Russia into some kind of
a war which has ignored the warnings A
very wise even sometimes liberal
Statesmen like George Kennan like Sam
Nunn like Daniel Patrick Moynihan like
lots of like Henry Kissinger actually
like lots of wise American foreign
policy Specialists who've said hey if
you guys in NATO aggress into Ukraine
that's going to destroy Ukraine status
as a buffer State between great powers
and it's going to provoke Russia to war
especially because NATO has been
aggressive in the past and invaded
countries in the past Russia is going to
view that as an unacceptable security
threat add on to that to Joe Biden
literally invited Russia to invade part
of Ukraine and said that if it were only
a minor incursion he wouldn't do very
much about it never mind that zelinski
has blamed Joe Biden for getting rid of
the sanctions on Russia which also
invited more Russian aggression never
mind all of that
zielinski has a little bit of a right to
be irritated here
he does I don't I don't like him that
much I don't like that he's trying to
provoke World War III I think Joe Biden
actually made the right call here to put
the brakes on Ukraine membership in NATO
I don't think Ukraine should joined NATO
I don't think Ukraine should joined the
European Union but zielinski has a
little bit of a right to be irritated
because the U.S and the West broadly
has been
encouraging Ukraine to make more and
more overtures toward the west
the U.S backed a color revolution in
Ukraine in 2014 the maidan revolution
which got rid of a pro-russian leader
and installed more pro-western leaders
in Ukraine head of the CIA landed in
Kiev two weeks after that Revolution
there's a little on the nose guys and
and so they've been dangling all of this
wonderful Western privilege in front of
Ukraine Ukraine gravitates toward that
privilege
now all of a sudden we say no actually
hold on you can't join no actually
we're going to give you Munitions we're
going to give you weapons
but we're not going to decisively end
this war right now and so Ukraine's
caught between a rock and a hard place
and and Ukraine is getting absolutely
pummeled right now and and they seem to
be in a pretty brutal position
because the West has no interest in this
war winding down anytime soon the West
benefits from this war the West gets to
turn Europe away from Russian energy
back toward American Energy the West
gets to strengthen the NATO alliance if
for no reason out of existential fear
and Russia benefits from prolonging this
war they're losing a lot of troops but
Russia also gets to gain more territory
in Ukraine it's hard to see how Russia
could possibly lose the territory that's
conquered in Ukraine at this point so
the only people who lose are Ukraine I
get why is zelinski is irritated by this
but this is why it was a a really
foolish strategy
for Ukraine to give up its status as a
buffer State buffer states are good
buffer states have worked for all of
human history when you're caught between
two big Powers it behooves you not to
pick sides it behaves you to play them
off against one another and get the best
benefits you possibly can from both but
because we don't study history anymore
because of Fallen human nature we just
keep repeating the same errors of the
past in this case potentially with
disastrous consequences if Solinski gets
his way with the consequence of World
War III boy wasn't that a great clip now
make sure you ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael Knowles YouTube channel
we'll see you next time